the White House cancels the Philadelphia
Eagles Paul Manafort allegedly gets
caught witness tampering and President
Trump talks about pardoning himself
we'll talk about all of it I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
all right so we have a lot to get to
today we will be talking about President
Trump disinviting the Philadelphia
Eagles and why that is a silly move we
will also be talking about Miss America
2.0 better than ever except for how it's
worse in every possible will explain
what I mean by that in just a second
first I want to make a couple
announcements we've decided to honor
father's day this year at the special
live stream when Tuesday June 12th 7:00
p.m. Eastern daily where God king Jeremy
Bourne will host a roundtable discussion
with me Ben Shapiro Andrew Clavin and
Michael Mills will discuss what
fatherhood means why fathers matter how
fatherhood will stand up against an
increasingly anti males culture and will
smoke cigars and ignore the fact that we
have wives and children subscribers will
be even will be able to answer well send
and write in live questions
okay just sending questions will answer
them and that is Tuesday June 12th 7
p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific you can find
our special live stream on Facebook and
YouTube so do not miss it alrighty so in
just a second I want to get to the
President and football and all the rest
of it first I want to say thanks to our
sponsor is over at Skillshare so you
need to make your resume better ok your
resume is fine I'm just telling you it's
ok likes nothing special make it better
ok make it better by adding a bunch of
skills you can put on your resume get
paid more change jobs if you're looking
to or just get better at something
you've always wanted to do that's what
Skillshare is for Skillshare is an
online learning platform with over
20,000 classes in business design
technology and more you can take classes
in social media marketing that's the one
that I've been taking illustration data
science mobile photography creative
writing human name it they've got it
needs our experts teaching them these
are 45 minute classes you can ask
questions it's really great whether
you're trying to deepen your
professional skill set start a side
hustle or just explore a new passion
skill share is there to keep you
learning and thriving again I know that
people who watch my show listen to my
show our devotees of information and
that's what skill share is a firehose of
information you can get all new skills
just by going to skill share again get
two months of skill share for just 99
cents right now join the millions of
students already learning there and you
get two months of skills for just 99
cents for my listeners two months of
unlimited access to over 20,000 classes
all you have to do is go to skill share
calm
Shapiro's that skill share calm slash
Shapiro again go to skill shared comm
slash Shapiro start that two months for
99 cents right now skill share calm
slash reparo and make your resume that
much better ok we begin today with a
controversy of the day the President of
the United States just inviting the
Philadelphia Eagles so here is sort of
backstory the Philadelphia Eagles win
the Super Bowl in shocking fashion over
the New England Patriots and then a
bunch of the players say they don't want
to come to the White House now I have
said for a long time I know there's been
an issue since Trump became president
and there are a lot of sports teams
where people don't want to show up
whenever they're invited to the White
House when I've said for a long times I
think White House invitations to sports
teams are stupid I don't like the
ceremonial aspect of the White House all
that much I think that it's mats of
monarchism I don't like the idea of some
King like figure who sits around and
gives out magical awards to people as
though he is the great leader of the
United States as opposed to a
constitutional official elected to do a
particular job so I'm not a big fan of
sports teams visiting the White House in
the first place but it's been the thing
since Ronald Reagan and Donald Trump
invites the Philadelphia Eagles to show
up and a bunch of them decide you know
what not a big fan of President Trump
don't want to show up now this is not
the first time this has happened
I remember Tim Thomas who was on the NHL
Stanley Cup winning Boston Bruins back
during the Obama administration decided
that he didn't want to go to the White
House and left made a huge deal out of
it how could he do such a thing and I
was on Tim Thomas's side if I don't feel
like showing up to the White House to
receive an award from Jimmy Carter or
something I'm not going to show up to
the White House to receive an award from
Jimmy Carter or Barack Obama then I
don't see a problem with that well a lot
of the Eagles were not fans of President
Trump which is not particularly shocking
given the political breakdown of the NFL
most of the players in the NFL vote
Democrat most of the players in the NFL
are not big fans of President Trump so
apparently a bunch of them didn't want
to show up there you know dozens and
dozens of NFL players on the
Philadelphia Eagles and that list had
been whittled down to about 10 who
actually wanted to show up and there was
a report that it was all the way down to
like three and a mascot so that was
embarrassing for the president so the
president then canceled but the
president didn't just canceled the event
the president then put out a statement
about canceling the event and here is
what he said he said quote the
Philadelphia Eagles are unable to come
to the White House with their fo team to
be celebrated tomorrow they disagree
with their president because he insists
that they proudly stand for the national
anthem hand down heart in honor of the
great men and women of our military and
the paper of our country the Eagles
wanted to send a smaller delegation but
the 1,000 fans planning to attend the
event deserve better
these fans are still invited to the
White House to be part of a different
type of ceremony one that will honor a
great country pay tribute to the heroes
you fight to protect it and loudly and
proudly play the national anthem I will
be there at 3 p.m.
the United States Marine Band and the
United States Army Corps is to celebrate
America okay so they're a bunch of
things that are wrong with this
statement so first of all I love the the
self-centeredness of the statement is
really quite astonishing they disagree
with their president because he insists
that they proudly stand for the national
anthem
I love the speaking of himself and
third-person that because Donald Trump
is their president he also tweeted out
about this as well and here's what
President Trump tweeted same sort of
message the Philadelphia Eagles football
team was invited to the White House
unfortunately only a small number of
players decided to come and we cancel
the event
staying in the locker room for the
playing of our National Anthem is as
disrespectful to our country as kneeling
sorry okay well here's the problem
nobody on the Eagles mules for the
national anthem no one on the
Philadelphia Eagles that entire season
knelt for the national anthem there's
one player who didn't preseason he was
cut no one on the Philadelphia Eagles
actually note for the national anthem or
attempt to dishonor the national anthem
yeah but the President of the United
States is attempting to jump on this
culture war again this kneeling from the
national anthem routine again and again
because he thinks he's gonna get a
political win out of it when in effect
all that happened here is that a bunch
of eagles didn't want to show up and
president Trump decided to respond
essentially by slandering the
Philadelphia Eagles this is one of the
drawbacks of having President Trump be
who he is characterized listen I said
yesterday on Fox News and I stand by
this president Trump in terms of
governments has governed more
conservatively than any president of my
lifetime for his first 500 days the
president of the United States has given
us all sorts of wins if you are a
conservative he's given us justice Gore
said she's turned out to be a great
justice he has given us a bunch of
appellate court a court appointees who
have been just terrific he's given us
regulatory reform he's given us tax cuts
he's given us a move the embassy to
Jerusalem he's given us a lot of wins
has the President of the United States
but one area where the president
continues to befuddle
is his approach to these issues now I
know that there are a lot of folks in
the Trump base will be angry at me for
saying that the president is blowing a
ton issues like this they think that
every time the president mentions the
national anthem it's a big win for him
but here's the problem if you actually
like the national anthem if you like the
idea of unifying American symbols what
you can't do is slander people with
regard to how they approach the national
anthem by telling lies about them for
your own personal grant Iseman if you
really do respect the national anthem
then you can't say people aren't
standing who
our standing you can't do that just out
of a fit of personal pique it's
worthless not only is it worthless it's
counterproductive and it shows that the
president isn't really all that upset
about the national anthem stuff he's
more upset about the fact that the
Eagles wouldn't visit the White House
and come and see him and pay homage to
him that's a big problem for me if you
truly care about the symbolism of
unifying American symbols like the
American flag or the national anthem you
shouldn't be using them as wedge issues
now I objected when NFL players did it I
object to NFL players kneeling I think
it's stupid that so many on the left are
fine with NFL players kneeling for the
national anthem I think that is a
cultural totem to which we all should
pay a certain amount of respect but the
president is doing no better when he
decides that he's going to take players
out of context unfortunately this
actually ended up being an issue on Fox
News so Fox News they actually did a
segment last night talking about all of
this and the producers cut a bunch of
pictures so Shannon Brumos was doing the
segment's and a bunch of people who were
producing decided they would put a bunch
of pictures of the Philadelphia Eagles
kneeling there's only one problem all
the pictures of the man kneeling are
them praying it's not actually for the
national anthem
so here's what it looked like on fox
news new tonight the president
announcing the philadelphia eagles will
not be visiting the White House tomorrow
to celebrate their Super Bowl victory
due to the national anthem controversy
the Eagles who won Super Bowl 52
apparently wanted to send a smaller
group of players a handful did not plan
to attend but it appears the president
said no thanks now the president says
he's still gonna host a different okay
so in any case you can see actually when
you watch this thing and don't just hear
it you can actually see that Fox is
flashing a bunch of pictures of people
kneeling for the national anthem that of
course is not true and Fox had to
retract that today which is what they
should do they got it wrong they
acknowledged that they got it wrong that
was wrong to slander these players
saying that they knelt before the
national anthem all of this drove Zach
Ertz he's a player on the Philadelphia
Eagles to tweet out about it he tweeted
quote this can't be serious praying
before games with my teammates well
before the anthem is being used for your
propaganda just said I feel like you
guys should have to be better than this
and of course I think exactly correctly
the Fox News apologized for all of this
Torrey Smith who's a wide receiver on
the Philadelphia Eagles also came out
and bashed President Trump he responded
by saying so many lies shaking my head
here are some facts now many people were
going to go
no one refused to go simply because
Trump insists folks stand for the anthem
the president continues to spread the
false narrative that players are
anti-military and then Philadelphia's
mayor Jim Kenney issued a statement he
said the Eagles call the birthplace of
our democracy home so it's no surprise
that this team embodies everything that
makes our country and our city great
their athletic accomplishments on the
field led to a historic victory this
year fans all across the country rally
behind them because we like to root for
the underdog and we feel joy when we see
the underdogs finally win I'm equally
proud of the Eagles activism off the
field these are players who stand up for
the causes they believe in and who
contribute in meaningful ways to their
community they represent the diversity
of our nation a nation in which we are
free to express our opinions disinviting
them from the White House only proves
that our presidents is not a true
patriot but a fragile egomaniac obsessed
with crowd size and afraid of the
embarrassment of throwing the parties
which no one wants to attend City Hall
is always open for celebration the
Philadelphia Eagles then issued their
own statement they said it has been
incredibly thrilling to celebrate our
first Super Bowl championship watching
the entire Eagles community come
together has been an inspiration we're
truly grateful for the support we've
received and we're looking forward to
continuing our preparations for the 2018
season so what should President Trump
have done here
you should just swallowed hard and have
the players who want to come you should
said listen I wish that more people were
gonna come to the people's house to
experience the glory of our democracy
and come see the White House in person
which is a really cool experience no
matter who the president says I wish
more of them are doing that I feel bad
that so many people feel polarized by
our politics and my invitation stands
they're free to come whenever they want
to come it would have been fine it would
have been fine but the president reacted
in thin-skinned fashion and it made him
look foolish he shouldn't have done this
and he certainly shouldn't have lied
about the members of the Philadelphia
Eagles kneeling for all of this now in
other news I will say the NFL Players
Association all responded the stupidest
way available also and this is the
reactionary time in which we live
Trump reacts to NFL players by doing
something dumb then NFL players react to
President Trump doing something dumb by
doing something even more dumb so the
NFL Players Association put out a
statement they said our union is
disappointed in the decision by the
White House to disinvite players from
the Philadelphia Eagles from being
recognized and celebrated by all
Americans for their accomplishment this
decision by the White House has led to
the cancellation of several player led
community service events for young
people in the Washington DC area
NFL players loved their country support
our troops give back to their
communities and strive to make America a
better place well I don't understand why
you had to cancel the player left
community service events when the
players associations got some money in
its coffers if they really want to help
out
bunch of community members in the
Washington DC area those players can
still go and do this and in fact if they
wanted to show up the president that's
exactly what they would do they would
say the president disinvited us from the
White House we won't go to the White
House anyway but we still want to help
out the community members in Washington
DC but because the world of politics
revolves purely and simply around
president Trump that means that
everything Trump does is the is the
black hole around which the entire
universe and politics revolves and
that's really stupid it also means the
president should be more careful about
the stuff that he says because this sort
of stuff does have an impact on how
Americans think about President Trump I
have a column up in National Review
today all about why Democrats are losing
why Democrats aren't unable to get it
together
and one of the reasons is because
Democrats have been fighting culture
wars that they are losing well when the
president decides to go too far in the
culture wars it doesn't help him it only
hurts him and only hurts the causes that
he is pushing again if you believe in
the national anthem believe people
should stand for it you cannot lie about
people who are standing for the national
anthem kneeling for the national anthem
for your own personal political game
okay I have a little more to say on this
but first I don't say thanks to our
sponsors over at my Patriots apply so
FEMA now estimates that most Americans
have no plan for an emergency and the
truth is that if an emergency happens I
live in California there's an earthquake
FEMA may not be able to get to you for
at least 48 72 hours well that is why
the best time to prepare is now
hurricane season is already active
earthquakes are rumbling out here don't
wait most emergencies or a power grid
attack will give you zero warning so act
by securing dependable food storage
right now my Patriot supply has the
perfect food kit to get you started
they've helped millions of people for a
decade now this week you can get their
four-week emergency food supply for just
99 bucks that is a low price for
security again you spend 99 bucks you
stick it in the closet you don't have to
worry about it last for 25 years in
storage and that means you're no longer
gonna have to worry if there's a natural
disaster there's a riot outside just
gotta hunker down for a little while
then you just have the food in the
closet and you're the person who is
smart enough to think of it years ago
and the stuff does taste good I mean
I've noticed that people around the
officer legitimately we have to actually
get another emergency food supply
because we don't starve the people here
but apparently they've been going
through the pantry and taking out the
cans of emergency food splatting eating
them now there's no emergency don't do
that guys okay but you can get the four
week emergency food supply right now for
99 bucks 888 803 1413 that's 888 803
1413 or prepare with been calm prepare
with Ben
come check it out a preparer with been
calm for that special deal again 99
bucks for a four week emergency food
supply 888 803 1413 okay so what should
the president do with regard to the fact
that so many cultural figures dislike
him the president should simply point
out the cultural figures dislike him
here is the nice thing about where the
president sits in the pop culture sphere
I've made this point over the past
couple of weeks with regard to Samantha
bee and the rest of the culture from the
fact the media are insane over president
Trump to the point where they are
speculating about missing Melania Trump
by the honestly Melania Trump had a
kidney surgery like three weeks ago and
the entire media since then has been
speculating about where Melania Trump
went there was a theory she'd been
abducted by aliens there's a theory that
President Trump was secretly beating her
in the basement of the White House or
some such nonsense okay everyone on the
Left has lost their minds the extent
that the Trump could simply sit back and
point at them and laugh so the
Philadelphia Eagles decided not to come
again the president could have said
listen that makes me sad I wish they
would come but they're not coming and it
would've been a good unifying moment for
the country but I guess that's on them
and the president could have done that
instead he decided to play right in
their hands because President Trump is a
counter-puncher it's it's a pathological
thing with the president this is just
his personality and he cannot avoid the
the feeling that he needs to hit
somebody back if he feels hit the
president is thin-skinned and he likes
to hit back that hitting back is a good
thing when it comes to some issues but
when it comes to issues like this where
we really should be getting a read
together and having a communal feeling
together around things like football it
is not a particularly useful thing again
I went to the Super Bowl last year and
when I went to the Super Bowl I have to
say the feeling of community in the
building was astonishing it was
astonishing I I can honestly say the
only time I felt something like it is
when you go to a synagogue or a church
event the feeling that everybody is
there from one common purpose to watch
football to enjoy each other's company
to to be in out of the cold honestly
where's in Minnesota waving the American
flag enjoying the patriotic aspects of
the national anthem and the and the Blue
Angels fly over and all the rest of it
and all that stuff should be unifying
the president should have gone forward
with the event he should have said to
the NFL players I'm sorry that you guys
didn't come you really would have
enjoyed it I think it would've been good
for the country for Eddie to show up and
we could have talked about some issues
that you guys are having you know
reaching out with an open hand is not a
sign of weakness mr. president reaching
out with an open hand to people who are
disdaining you sometimes looks like
strength sometimes it looks like you're
going
beyond the call of duty and I think the
President Trump could stand to do that a
little bit more and I hope that he does
I hope that in the future the President
of the United States decides that he is
going to reach out to people on the
other side of the aisle who have a
pathological dislike for him and in
doing so maybe open some hearts and open
some minds rather than lying about the
members of the Philadelphia Eagles which
I just think is a huge mistake okay
so meanwhile speaking of other stupid
news the Miss America competition has
now decided that they are no longer
going to be having a swimsuit
competition
so gretchen carlson who's on the board
over there she's a former Miss America
herself I believe and she of course was
the subject of a me-too scandal because
Roger Ailes had allegedly sexually
harassed her well gretchen carlson comes
forward and she says we are now going to
do a Miss America 2.0 makeover oh yeah
so we are no longer a pageant we are a
competition we will no longer judge our
candidates on their outward physical
appearance that's huge
that's human and that means that we will
no longer have a swimsuit competition
and so we're no longer judging women
when they come out in their chosen
attire their evening wear whatever they
choose to do it's gonna be what comes
out of their mouths that we're
interested in when they talk about their
social impact initiative women oh that's
really what it's gonna be about so Miss
America 2.0 is actually going to be like
the Kennedy Center Honors and Madeline
Albright
will be your Miss America 2018 because
we're no longer taking physical
appearance into account Hillary Clinton
finally has a shot at being beloved by
America she can be Miss America 2018 if
she so chooses she can walk out wearing
a giant trench coat and she can be
awarded this because physical appearance
no longer counts okay so here's why this
is so dumb and I upset about this by the
way no I'm not upset about this in fact
I think the Miss America competition was
always stupid right I'm the guy when I
was a teenager used to unsubscribe from
the swimsuit edition of Sports
Illustrated because I thought it was
basically softcore pornography right I
mean the fact is that when you are
looking at the Victoria's Secret catalog
we may have this Victoria's Secret
models on the runway people are not
watching the Victoria's Secret Fashion
Show for the fashion if those were
400-pound women walking down the runway
with Victoria's Secret fashion on the
ratings would be nil it's an excuse for
dudes to watch scantily clad beautiful
women walk around and then they can
always say to their wives well I was
just watching because I really loved the
fashion aspect by the way women if you
are taken in by this your boys lying to
you okay he's not watching the
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show because
he's mo
interested in the new styles of bra and
panties that are coming out he's
thinking about what happens when those
bra and panties are not part of the show
at all okay that's just the way the men
work note to note to women all over the
world the same thing was true of the
Miss America pageant so as a religious
person and an advocate of modesty for
both men and women I'm perfectly happy
with there being no swimsuit competition
in the Miss America pageant I also will
acknowledge that the Miss America
competition was always about the
swimsuit competition okay there's a
reason that Miss America features a
bunch of beautiful women and not a bunch
of plus-size models or plus-sized non
models who have done wonderful charity
work mother Teresa was never going to be
in the Miss America 2.0 pageant it's not
because she wasn't a charitable human
being it's because the Miss America
pageant was not about that and here's
the part that I find puzzling so I
understand my own perspective on this
I'm a religious person I think it's
stupid to judge women by their bodies
that doesn't say that doesn't mean that
when you're entering a relationship
sexual attraction isn't important it's
deeply important it's not say that I
don't think that people of all sexes
should stay in shape I think that they
should to the best of their ability it
is to say however that I've always been
an advocate for modesty because I think
that if you want if women want to be
treated as more than pieces of meat by
men then it behooves them to understand
how men think and men tend to see
scantily clad women in sexual ways
that's just the way the men think that
is nature that is the way it works so
that means that if you put on a little
bit more clothing men are more likely to
see you as a proper businesswoman as
opposed to if you walk into the office
wearing a bra and panties just telling
you okay men are not thinking about your
capacity for social media marketing at
that point but here's here's where I
find the arguments and left kind of
weird so I've heard from the left that a
woman wearing a bathing suit is actually
empowering that scantily-clad women are
empowering that in fact stormy Daniels
is an example of female empowerment
because she chooses to be a porn star
and have sex with randos on camera I've
heard that this is the essence of female
empowerment and then if you say that
acting immodestly is not female
empowerment it actually is degradation
and it is catering to the worst
instincts of men and the most lewd
instincts of men if you say that then
you are anti-feminist your anti female
but now I'm hearing that it's
anti-feminist to allow the swimsuit
competition to go forward but I was
under the impression that all these
women consented to be part of the
swimsuit competition but this was
something they wanted to do that that
there wasn't the the leadership of the
Miss America pageant wasn't down in the
in the
room whippin the girls to get in their
bathing suits but the girls all chose to
be part of this you can't have it both
ways ladies okay if you are going to
suggest that it is female empowerment to
get unclad whenever you please then you
can't then claim that you have done
something feminist by telling women that
they should no longer wear bathing suits
and there shouldn't be a competition for
bathing suits or anything like that
I like that maybe what they should have
done is they should have said listen
this is a consensual competition we can
go for it however we want just in the
future we're gonna do evening gowns
instead of instead of bathing suits by
the way it's a lie the idea that they're
going to award this to Madeleine
Albright or Janet Napolitano or anybody
else who is is not the most beautiful
elk is just silly okay just it's
ridiculous Rosie O'Donnell ain't winning
the Miss America 2.0 it's not happening
it's gonna be a beautiful woman from
California who would look good in a
bathing suit or an evening gown or an
anything else and and anything else they
say to you about this is a lie but it's
all it's all just silliness it's all
just silliness and demonstrates the
internal contradictions inside the
radical feminist movement okay meanwhile
in in other news but the the situation
with Robert the situation with Robert
Muller is heating up and that situation
is not particularly good for Paul Manta
Ford so I'm gonna get to that in just
second first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at texture so are you
paying attention to the news do you pay
attention to the news you love
information I do and that's why some of
the best journalism that's been
happening over the last couple of years
has been happening in magazines The New
Yorker has done wonderful work in
exposing the me to scandal Ronan Farrow
doing amazing work over there there are
a lot of good articles over the Atlantic
even though I'm not a big fan of how
Jeffrey Goldberg has run the place there
are a lot of worthwhile interesting
articles over at the Atlantic people
Cosmo Entertainment Weekly there's a lot
of interesting good and interesting just
fascinating stuff happening in the
magazine space right now which is why
you need texture texture is the magazine
act it's an app it's got all of these
magazines more than 200 top magazines
all in one places must have app from
people looking to read up on what's
going on
they've got quality journalism and of
course the best photos and interviews
and perspectives and you can stay
connected today instead of you having to
spend $4.99 a month for each one of
these magazines and spend hundreds of
dollars to subscribe to 200 of them you
get full subscriptions to all of them
with just one low price start your
seven-day fruit trout right now at
texture comm slash Ben that's texture
calm slash Ben and you get the back
issues as well
textures
so I spending try texture for free today
for seven days see how much you liked it
you were you will really enjoy it my
wife loves it as well don't wait to
start reading the latest issues its
texture calm /ban texture calm /ban to
start that free trial okay so the latest
news in the Muller gate situation is
that Robert Muller the special
investigator is now accusing Paul mana
for Trump's former campaign manager have
attempted witness tampering so here is
the story from ABC News special counsel
Robert Muller was seeking to revoke the
bail of President Donald Trump's former
campaign chairman Paul Manafort for
allegedly tampering with witnesses in
the year-long probe into Russian
meddling in the 2016 election according
to a court filing on Monday night
attorneys with the special counsel of
the accused man afford of quote
attempting to tamper with potential
witnesses while awaiting his trial which
thereby quote has violated the
conditions of his release so in other
words poem anna fort has on an ankle
bracelet and he's under constant
surveillance and he's trying to tamper
with witnesses anyway got to admire the
dude's commitment to criminality my
goodness in february within days of
Muller's filing a 32 count superseding
indictment against manna fort the former
trump campaign chairman allegedly
contacted two individuals who worked
with him on a lobbying scheme to aid his
kremlin backed ukrainian clients the two
individuals were member of the Hapsburg
group described by Muller in February
superseding indictment of Manta for has
a group of former senior European
politicians to take positions favorable
to Ukraine including by lobbying in the
United States so he was reaching out to
some of his European friends Muller
steam is asking that the Washington DC
federal court revoked manna forts
current ten million dollar bail and is
asking that the court promptly scheduled
a hearing called for by the statute to
determine mana forts release status now
what's weird about this of course is
that the day before all of this broke
president Trump was tweeting about palm
Ana fort with no obvious reason to do so
he tweeted out quote there's only one of
two people left who could become
president why wouldn't the FBI or
Department of Justice have told me that
they were secretly investigating Paul
Manafort on charges that were 10 years
old and had previously been dropped
during my campaign should have told me
Paul Manafort came into the campaign
very late and was with us for a very
short period of time he represented
Ronald Reagan Bob Dole and many others
over the years but we should have been
told that Comey and the boys were doing
a number on him and he wouldn't have
been hired okay well to be fair everyone
on the right who knew who Paul Manafort
was was warning presidents from not to
hire him as his campaign manager at
about the time that he was hired now I
guess the idea here is that the DOJ or
the FBI should have told Trump
manna fort but remember the DOJ and the
FBI were suspicious that members of the
Trump campaign other members of the
Trump campaign were participating in
Russian collusion and it doesn't seem
completely out of bounds to me for the
FBI or the DOJ so you simply say well
why would we tell President Trump about
all of this we suspect the President
Trump might be more of a window than a
wall when it comes to stopping
information that can help us capture
these guys which brings us to some big
questions that I still have about the
spy gate scandal so yesterday a guy
whose show I really enjoyed a mangie
know he responded to a show that I did
on Thursday all about spy gauge 2018
these of course are the allegations that
the Trump campaign was spied on by the
FBI at the behest of the Obama DOJ and
the Hillary campaign in order to take
down Trump's campaign somehow during the
election and I expressed three questions
during the show on Thursday question
number one was why didn't Hillary or the
FBI or the DOJ released the most
damaging information about the Trump
campaign if this was in fact a setup in
a hit the most damaging information that
happened during the Trump campaign was
the Donald Trump jr. meeting at Trump
Tower with Natalia Veselin skya
and the emails that were sent by Donald
Trump jr. to a Russian connected agent
that the Trump family had worked with
before in which Trump jr. expressed his
willingness to hear information from the
Russian government about Hillary Clinton
why didn't we hear about that until
after the election if this was a setup
why didn't we hear about that why didn't
we hear about George papadopolis who's
apparently going around bragging to the
Australian ambassador that he had met up
with a Russian source who was going to
provide him information on Hillary
Clinton mails we didn't hear any of that
stuff until after the election the only
thing that we heard is that there were
there was an investigation going on we
heard that in the late stages of the
campaign but the actual headline from
the New York Times was investigation
took place and nothing was found
basically this is late October I think
is October 30th was the New York Times
story so that was question number one
why didn't Hillary in the FBI release
the most damaging information entering
the campaign so we already knew about
Manta for four years the idea that there
were leaks about how man afford and
utterly unconvincing Paul Manafort again
for years had been suspected of being a
Kremlin agent you know that had been
going back long before the 2016
elections that was question number one
question number two is why didn't the
FBI target other members of Team Trump
so if Spygate is a thing if the FBI was
in fact targeting the entire Trump team
if they suspected the entire Trump team
of collusion to the extent that they
were
wiretapping Trump as Trump claimed in
Trump Tower in that tweet from January
2017 if that was the case then why were
the only people who were targeted inside
the Trump campaign people who actually
had pretty solid ties with the Kremlin
okay those people would be the people
that I mentioned before Robert Gates and
Paul Manafort and Carter Page and George
papadopolis several of whom have already
pled guilty to lying to the FBI or to
other charges related to this particular
investigation so Dan Bronzino responded
that when I asked this question I was
ignoring that Trump jr. and Trump had
actually been targeted the Trump jr.
targeting he suggests was the Natalia
vessel Mnet's kaya meeting was being run
by a fusion GPS which had been hired by
Hillary to gather dirt on the Trump
campaign and therefore this was some
sort of setup by Hillary Clinton I think
dan admits rightly that there is not
evidence to suggest that Hillary Clinton
was behind the setup of the Trump Tower
meeting again there is no evidence to
suggest that there's certainly no
evidence to suggest the FBI was behind
the setup of the Trump Tower meeting now
is it suspicious
that fusion GPS was involved with the
Trump Tower meeting yes it is suspicious
is that enough for me to go all the way
and say that Trump jr. was being
targeted not really not really it's hard
for me to go all the way without that
evidence I'm happy to hear more evidence
but I'm not willing to go all the way
with all of that there's no evidence the
FBI particularly or the DOJ used this
meeting to target Trump jr. now Vaughn
Geno's claimed that all of this was
designed to notice that they could use
the two-hopper rules so they could get
information on Donald Trump I haven't
seen the information they got on Trump
if that's the case at this point so
maybe when the evidence comes out that's
what they were doing then we can talk
about it Bunji NOAA also claims that
Donald Trump was targeted by the steal
dossier so the steal dossier obviously
is is originally funded by the
Washington by the Washington free beacon
it was not the seal that's that's in the
statement the steel dossier was not
funded by the Washington free beacon an
oppo research foul was started funded by
the Washington free beacon later on the
Hillary campaign picked up the Oppo
research file from fusion GPS and then
went out and hired a Christopher Steele
Fusion GPS Ted using the Hillary Clinton
camp as sort of the funders and still
put together this dossier now it is
false to say that we know that
everything in the dossier is false okay
we do not know everything in the dossier
is false we know a lot of things in the
dossier are BS I've said for a long time
I think a lot of the stuff there is BS
we don't know that everything in the
dossier
is false seal has been a source that was
used by the FBI multiple times to
suggest that the FBI was targeting
president Trump because they used
Christopher steel as a source
you then have to rule out every
investigation Christopher Steele ever
did also that would bring us to our
third question right and our third
question here well I'm gonna get to that
in just one second first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at man
crate so Father's Day is coming up guys
like you it is up to you men women you
all have dads and it's time for you to
get something nice for your dad because
your dad's doing so much stuff for you I
mean your dad used to drive you to
school and listen to you whine about
your friends and all that stuff will get
him something nice on this Father's Day
and the best thing you can get him is a
man crate they have all these wonderful
kits they have the whiskey appreciation
crate but when your father doesn't feel
like listening to you anymore they've
the knife making kit for the hands-on
dads and all of their all of their kits
come in awesome packaging so I have a
bunch of poker chips that came in in
ammo box which is pretty awesome and as
I've said before once I get friends I
will definitely definitely use it also
most of these come in actual crates they
come in like a wooden crate with a
crowbar and you got prise it opened
demonstrating what a man he is with his
man crate it's just it's it's an awesome
gift you're really gonna enjoy it Plus
everyman crate comes with a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee it's a
gift experience get your special
Father's Day discount today let Metin
crates at man crates calm slash Ben
that's man crates calm slash Ben it's a
limited time offer go to for Father's
Day go today right now man crates calm
slash Ben let them know that we sent you
by using that slash Ben and there's a
special Father's Day discount for you
when you use that slash pen man crates
dot-com slash pen so go check it out
right now okay so I have a little bit
more on spy gate and the associated
issues but first you're gonna have to go
over to daily wear comm so for $9.99 a
month you get the rest of this show live
rustic laven show live the rest and
nolza show live you also get to be part
of our mailbag on Fridays
which is super awesome and by the way
there is more great news for podcast
listeners the Ben Shapiro show along
with our other daily where podcast is
now available on Amazon Alexa and the
Google home device so your home can be
filled with the rich supple tones of my
voice with a simple voice command the
mellifluous joy of this voice emanating
from your Alexa device with Alexa you
have to enable the skill it's like
adding an app you go Alexa enable the
Ben Shapiro shows skill and then you can
tell her to play or
open Alexa played the Ben Shapiro show
Google doesn't need to be added by a
user but you have to speak very clearly
for her to understand as though you are
in a foreign country and you're an
American and if you speak louder and
then suddenly they will understand what
you're talking about say okay google
talk to ben shapiro show and then it
will actually work so check it out and
your device should be able to play the
podcast and your quality of life will be
immeasurably improved so if you need to
review those directions just go to the
pin post at daily wear twitter or daily
wear Facebook for all the information if
you want the annual subscription there's
$99 a year and it brings you this the
very greatest in all beverage vessels
the left dis tears hot or cold tumblr ah
view the glory before you look at this
it's just magnificent I mean just gaze
upon it and weep it's it's it's
incredible
also when you get the membership it also
helps us bring you great shows like we
had Joe Rogan on our Sunday special last
week go check that out it's already the
hottest thing on YouTube it was awesome
and next Sunday I believe is Jonah
Goldberg so internal Goldberg is coming
up on her Sunday special as well so
check that out we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so as I say I had three questions about
Spygate question number one was why
didn't the worst stuff come out during
the campaign question number two is why
didn't the FBI target other members of
Team Trump tan Mangino had been upset
with my analysis of this issue or at
least he had challenged my analysis of
this issue and and I enjoyed dance Joe
so I felt like it was worthwhile
responding to some of his responses so
one of the things that he claims and
what Spygate is all about is that there
was a spy targeting team Trump the guys
name is Stephen helper Stephen Harper
has worked with a bunch of Republican
administrations in the past he was
apparently asked by the FBI to meet with
Carter Paige and George papadopolis
after Papadopoulos bragged to the
Australian High Commissioner to Great
Britain Alexander Alexander Downer about
Hillary's emails and after Kyra Paige
organised a visit to Moscow that was
greenlit by the Trump campaign the fact
that he was asked to do so before there
was a formal opening of an investigation
into Trump rush conclusion doesn't mean
an awful lot and to claim that he's a
spy okay don't call it a spy you want to
call it informing out really care about
the language it's what he did that
counts what he did is he approached Kyra
Paige and he offered him like a couple
of thousand bucks to write an essay and
that was pretty much the extent of it
from what I can tell that doesn't sound
to me like mole inside the Trump
campaign in the way that is being made
out okay finally third question why
doesn't Trump just declassify all this
material and this is the big one why
doesn't President Trump if the Carter
page FISA warrant was badly gotten as
Devon hoon as is claimed why doesn't
Trump just declassify it if in fact the
FBI was spying on Trump in nefarious
fashion there'd be documentation to show
that why doesn't Trump just reveal all
that stuff so Dan has a theory and Dan's
theory is that Trump doesn't do this
because this would somehow interfere
with or prejudice ongoing leak
investigations but these two issues are
unrelated as a lawyer illegal leaks are
still illegal even if the president
makes the underlying material material
unclassified post-hoc so if I leak
classified material and it's classified
today and five years from now the
president declassify that material I was
still breaking the law when I leaked the
classified material so declassifying it
doesn't change anything
Trump could easily declassify the pucara
page FISA warrant for example without
disrupting any ongoing investigation he
hasn't and he should I've heard so much
about it at some point why don't we just
hear the rest of it we keep hearing do
J's and being forthcoming with the House
Intelligence Committee that is true and
that is fair and that's why I think
Trump should just go over their head and
declassify this stuff like if someone
who wants to get to the truth if the DOJ
is in fact stonewalling and that's
Trump's
play not mine right Trump is saying the
DOJ is stonewalling well if he's
stonewalling then why not just go over
their head and he classified this
doesn't make a lot of sense to me
and the idea that there is some sort of
you know ongoing investigation that's
why Trump doesn't declassify I'd have to
see again more evidence maybe that's
true but I'd have to see more evidence
of it I don't think it's as crystal
clear as Dan is suggesting finally there
are two other issues that have been
surrounding Spygate that are worth
pointing out first trey Gowdy said last
week didn't believe the Spygate
narrative he said quote I think the FBI
if they were at the table this morning
they would tell you that Russia was the
target and Russia's intentions for our
country were the target the fact the two
people who are loosely connected to the
Trump campaign may have been involved
doesn't diminish the fact that Russia
was the target and not the campaign
okay this was in fact the line that the
Trump administration was using for
months then they flipped and they said
that the Trump campaign itself was
targeted what they originally said is
we're not guilty originally this was a
counterintelligence investigation that
was aimed at the Russians and the fact
is that President Trump is not a target
in fact that's why Trump probably fired
James Comey as he went to Comey said the
list just say I'm not a target and Comey
wouldn't and Trump rightly said why
won't you and Comey said well because I
think it would be a bad idea and Trump
fired him out of frustration and now
they're saying that Trump was targeted
by the FBI and that he really was the
target of the investigation well he
can't have it both ways either he was
the target of the investigation or he
was not the target of the investigation
I guess the happy medium would be he was
the target of the investigation and the
evidence just didn't arrive to indict
him but again I'd have to see more
evidence that he was the target from
specifically as opposed to particular
members of the Trump campaign amid the
broad suspicion of Russian collusion
with the Trump campaign which again
wouldn't end with the indictment of
particular officials not with their
there's no Trump campaign to indict you
can't actually do a criminal indictment
against the quote/unquote Trump campaign
you can only indict people who knew
about things and committed crimes okay
finally the bunch you know said that I
got it wrong when I said Trump had
openly stated they were literally stated
that he'd fired James Comey over Russia
here is what Donald Trump said about
firing James Comey and in fact when I
decided to just do it
ie fire Comey I said to myself I said
you know this Russia thing with Trump
and Russia is a made-up story nine ever
claims that Trump fired Comey to
obstruct the Russia investigation in
fact I've been saying since the day
Comey was fired that he did not do that
I have been said I wrote an article that
day saying that Comey was fired because
he refused to clear Trump in the Russia
investigation when Trump obviously
wasn't under-investing
but for Trump to claim that is that
commis firing had nothing to do with the
Russia cases which is what he claimed on
Twitter that is just not true that's
just not now with all of that said there
are serious questions to be asked about
the Muller investigation what's the
scope of the investigation
why hasn't in Pitt restricted to the
issues at hand ie Trump Russia collusion
why we're members of the Obama holdover
team leaking like sibs criminally after
the election why hasn't the DOJ turned
over documentation to the House
Intelligence Committee why did the DOJ
struggle so hard to avoid turning over
information that really could have been
declassified why did James Comey keep
contemporaneous notes about Trump not
Obama why did he leaked information to
his friends outside the government I'm
not saying that it's impossible that the
FBI and DOJ combined to target Trump
during the election cycle as
quote-unquote insurance against Trump
winning although I'm still wondering how
that insurance was supposed to work if
they never revealed the information but
I'm opening the argument I just need to
see more information and I haven't seen
the evidence quite yet
so when the evidence presents itself I
am happy to change my mind on all of
this well this has led to a real break
sort of inside the conservative movement
Rudy Giuliani has been ripping up and
down trey Gowdy over the last couple of
days
here's Rudy Giuliani the president's
lawyer on these matters talking Chris
Cuomo on CNN about it and they said
there was no somebody's lawyer I don't
know the last time they practice
criminal law so don't don't tell me I'd
like both of them but they're not the
lawyers they don't have the awesome
responsibility or representing somebody
who is being treated in a way that you
wouldn't treat a common criminal so
don't tell me
dowdy Gowdy and Nunez I got like more
experience than the two of them by ten
okay so he's angry at both Gowdy add
Nunez right not just not just dragged
out he's also angry at a Devin Nunez
because Devin Nunez has suggested that
trey Gowdy may not be entirely wrong so
if the idea here is that that Rudy
Giuliani has the most experience and
therefore he knows what spikes like trey
Gowdy was a prosecutor it was a federal
prosecutor and trey Gowdy does know what
he's talking about there's a rumor that
there was not a rumor there was a report
going around for Molly Hemingway over at
the Federalists saying well trey Gowdy
hasn't seen the underlying document so
how can clear the FBI trey Gowdy has
seen precisely the same documents that
Devin Nunez has and he's come to some
opposite conclusions which suggests an
honest difference of opinion not the
trey Gowdy has been somehow picked up by
the deep state and turned
remember just months ago he was ripping
on james comey with the same alacrity as
president Trump okay meanwhile President
Trump has been talking about pardoning
himself again I want to talk about that
so President Trump like he came out the
other day and he said I have the power
to pardon myself this is at best unclear
so the constitutional pardon power is
laid forth in in article 3 of the
article 2 rather of the Constitution of
the United States is article 2 section 2
Clause 1 so the presidential have the
power to grant reprieves and pardons for
offenses against the United States
except in cases of impeachment so in
other words the president can't pardoned
himself after he's impeached and
convicted in the Senate so you can't
pardon somebody who has been convicted
in the Senate you can pardon somebody
who was about to be impeached that's
what happened to Richard Nixon with
Gerald Ford according to the Heritage
Foundation the power to pardon is one of
the least limited powers granted to the
president in the Constitution the only
limits mentioned in the Constitution are
the pardons that are limited to offenses
against the United States and they
cannot effect an impeachment process or
a previous commutation
or lessening of a sentence already
imposed a pardon completely wipes out
the legal effects of a conviction the
presidential power to pardon was derived
from the Royal English prerogative of
Kings this is why I don't like the
pardon power all that much it's not
clear how far the pardons can go pardons
have been used for broader public policy
purposes of ensuring peace and
tranquility in the case of uprisings
which is what happened after the shays
rebellion and the whiskey rebellion for
example and the scope of the pardon
power according to heritage remains
quite broad almost plenary Justice
Stephen field wrote in 1867 if granted
before conviction it prevents any of the
penalties and disabilities consequence
upon conviction from attaching thereto
it says the possibility of a president
pardoning himself for a crime is not
precluded by the explicit language of
the Constitution but a broader reading
of the Constitution and the general
principles of the traditions of the
United States might lead to the
conclusion that a self pardon is
constitutionally impermissible it would
seem to violate the principle that a man
should not be a judge in his own case
that the rule of law is supreme in the
United States is a nation of laws not
men and that the president is not above
the law is according to James v nur
professor of public policy at George
Mason University
writing for heritage that's probably my
reading is the president doesn't have
the constitutional power to pardon
himself because it puts him above checks
and balances that are inherent now you
could make the counter-arguments a the
president can pardon himself but he
could still be impeached so in reality
the checks and balances still exist I
think today CK said best alan dershowitz
he's been very warm toward the Trump
administration legally he says he
doesn't think the president Trump has
the power to pardon himself look I
disagree with a great deal of what has
gone on today from the White House I
don't think that a president necessarily
has the power to pardon himself I wrote
a column today in the hill I wrote one a
year ago in which I said nobody knows
the answer to that question it's clearly
on a blank slate nobody should be saying
either that a president clearly has the
power to pardon himself or a president
doesn't have the power we just don't
know the answer to that question we will
probably never find it out and that's
exactly right this is the real question
is why Trump is even talking about this
in the first place
he doesn't need a pardon himself it's
stupid to talk about pardoning yourself
if you're not going to do it
particularly because it just makes you
look suspicious now I know that
President Trump likes to mouth off on
Twitter that's his thing but I'm not
sure why this is useful to him chuck
Grassley who again has supported
President Trump pretty heavily in the
Senate he says maybe Trump needs a new
lawyer if he's being told this stuff if
I were President in those days and I had
a lawyer that told me I could part
myself
I think I'd hire a lawyer and this is
part of the problem for President Trump
is that he's so inconsistent in his
public face on this stuff if he just
presents in a public face which is I'm
innocent
do your worst there's really not a
problem here see what you're gonna see
and then he said but I got to say the
scope of this investigation is beyond
any sort of limitation at this point and
we need investigations into leaking I'd
be with him 100% of the way here but
it's all the confused language coming
out from the White House that is really
not useful so for example the White
House has given a bunch of different
stories all of them conflicting about
who drafted the statements in the
aftermath of the Trump jr. Trump Tower
story right there's a statement that's
put out by Trump jr. at the time talking
about how the meeting really was about
Russian adoptions and there was
originally a denial from the White House
the president Trump had anything to do
with that statement then it was admitted
that President Trump in fact essentially
drafted the statement here's Rudy
Giuliani being asked about it on CNN you
think Jay Sekulow lie maybe he just got
it wrong like like I've gotten it I got
a few things wrong at the beginning of
the investigation I'm meaning my
knowledge this is a complex
investigation first week or so I got
few things wrong and then it was
clarified in a letter and that's the
final position you can make a mistake
and then if you don't if you don't if
you want to you could say it's a lie but
it was a mistake I swear to God it was a
mistake okay so so if they're swearing
it's a mistake that's fine but then it's
it's it's very difficult to tell when a
mistake is being made when a fib is
being made because if the mistakes all
leaning in one direction he starts to
think somebody is fibbing to you again
does any of this kind of thing any of
this stacks up to a hill of beans in the
end I don't think any of this ends up
being anything I don't think Trump has
indicted I don't think anybody whose ki
around him is indicted other than the
people we've already heard I haven't
seen the evidence of any of that stuff
the point I'm making here is that the
president ought to be focusing on bigger
things and the distractions of the
Muller investigation are not
particularly helpful to his to his
administration he should be avoiding
them himself and blowing them up bigger
than they are
okay time for some things I like and
then some things I hate so thing I like
so Bill Bryson is a very popular writer
I picked up one of his books I've never
read any of the stuff he wrote a series
of columns called I'm a stranger here
myself all about how he had been in
Britain for 20 years and then he came
back and lived in New Hampshire and it's
a very charming funny book all about
sort of experiencing life in America
anew Bryson leans to the left on a bunch
of issues but that really shouldn't
inhibit your enjoyment of the book at
all America's an amazing place it's an
amazing place and a lot of people who
are in America and don't appreciate how
great America is have spent very little
time in other countries they're talking
about countries in which they've spent
not a lot of time there's a reason
everybody is clamoring to get into the
United States is because America is the
dream right New Hampshire where Bill
Bryson leaves it lives that is the dream
and he basically acknowledges as much
even though he tends toward the left
side of the aisle on a lot of key issues
so check that out I'm a stranger here by
Bill Bryson really worth the read and a
lot of fun Drake okay time for some
quick things that I hate
as we discussed yesterday Bill Clinton
has been making the rounds and the fact
that Bill Clinton is still considered a
respected voice in left-wing circles is
just insane so you remember during the
last campaign Kirsten Gillibrand he's
the senator from New York originally she
said that she thinks that President
Clinton should have resigned after the
Lewinsky scandal and after he was caught
in a perjury trap well Clinton has now
responded to Kirsten Gillibrand and he
says well you know not really I
shouldn't resign she's living in a
different context well I just disagree
with her I mean I think you know just
you have to really ignore what the
context was in but you know she's living
in a different context and she did it
for different reasons so I but I just
disagree with her he's so gross what is
the different context it's exactly the
same context hey it is bad she sexually
harassed the help it's bad to use your
leverage as president of the United
States it's up to 19 year old girls
working for you it's a bad idea it makes
you a bad person when you're married
particularly it makes you a bad person
so um no you know Bill Clinton still
doing this routine of the hilarious part
about this is the media sudden awareness
their sudden awakening to the fact that
Bill Clinton is despicable
here's Mika Brzezinski on MSNBC they're
talking about Bill Clinton it has been
for decades an unbelievable double
standard that the Clintons have used and
abused where nobody is allowed to go
there on this issue and in the age of me
too women are supposed to go there and
men by the way we're supposed to be able
to say what the difference is between
right and wrong and when you have done
something wrong
you were supposed to own it and not talk
about facts distorted facts and
obstructed facts my god he sounded like
Trump I love that this just hit them I
love this just hit them like it just hit
me and Joe who pumped Trump during the
primaries it just hit them that Trump is
kind of like Clinton right yeah we knew
that guys we're pretty much aware of
that like the whole campaign we're
pretty much aware that Trump and Clinton
used to be buddy-buddy and we've been on
top of this thing for I don't know 20
years and now you're proclaiming that Oh
Mike I'm just so shocked by Bill Clinton
my goodness my goodness it's like Claude
Rains in Casablanca I'm shocked shocked
to find this gambling going on here here
winning sir
thank you very much right I mean it's
that
feel it's just absurd but yeah this is
why the left can't get a grip on
anything suddenly their eyes have been
awakened they've been opened by trumpet
until of course the next Democrat is up
for election and it turns out that
Democrat was shtupping interns and lying
about it
then we'll just go right back to why are
Republicans so snooty why can't
Republicans just accept that we have new
social standards in the United States
that's the way the left operates
unfortunately and Democrats have
operated I hate this kind of
partisanship okay time for a quick
Federalist paper we didn't do one
yesterday so Federalist 31 Alexander
Hamilton writing he's still defending
general taxation by the federal
government and talking about the
argument that we should not be just
trying to go to the states and asking
them for money that instead the states
should actually go over the head of the
state governments and we can tax
citizens directly so he says as theory
and practice conspire to prove that the
power of procuring revenue is
unavailable when exercised over the
states and their collective capacities
the federal government must have
necessity be invested with an
unqualified power of Taxation in the
ordinary modes he's saying here is that
under the Articles of Confederation the
federal government gained money simply
by going to the states and asking for
levies and the states basically said go
screw yourself and then they'd know any
money so he said well if the states are
going to be a burden here then we just
have to go around the states otherwise
we can't have a functional federal
government and then he says in the end
this is an important line he says we
have to rely on people in the end to
maintain the balance between the states
and the federal government he says the
moment we launch into conjectures about
the usurpations of the federal
government we get into an unfathomable
and fairly put ourselves out of the
reach of all reasonings what he's saying
here is everybody is complaining that
the federal government might usurp all
tax money and leave the states bereft
but if we imagine worst-case scenario
we're never gonna be able to do anything
here his imagination may range and
pleasure until it gets bewildered amidst
the labyrinths of an enchanted castle
and knows not on which side to turn to
extricate itself from the perplexities
into which it has so rashly adventured
whatever may be the limits or
modifications or the powers of the Union
it is easy to imagine an endless train
and possible dangers and by indulging in
excess of jealousy and timidity
we may bring ourselves to a state of
absolute scepticism any resolution he
says listen we have to make a call here
and we're going to have to determine
exactly how the checks and balances work
now the truth is that the federal
taxation power was just fine up until
the sixteenth amendment to the
Constitution which allowed the income
tax okay up until then the federal
government was not an overweening
institution that was dedicated to
sucking as much money as possible out of
your pocket
it was really at the beginning of the
20th century that all of that changed so
Hamilton's critique of the
anti-federalists is Right the
anti-federalists critique of Hamilton
ended up being right in the long run
because the reality is the federal
government did usurp an enormous amount
of revenue and they continued to do so
on a daily basis all across the country
okay so we'll be back here tomorrow with
all the latest I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens edited by Alex and Garo audio
is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup
is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro show
is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing